طيب في قضيه اقرب للخيال مشاهدينا وبعد
400 عام من اعدامهم برات ولايه كناتيكيت
12 شخصا كانوا قد ادينوا باعمال السحر
والشعوذه ظل في موضوعها هذه التهمه كانت
قد وجهت لهؤلاء الاشخاص ايام الحقبه
الاستعماريه في امريكا في منتصف القرن
السابع عشر دبي الله يرحمهم مسؤوليه
الولايه او مسؤولوه عفوا الولايه
الامريكيه قرروا ان الاشخاص المعدومين من
عدمه يعني هم بريئين من التهمه بس بعد شو
وصفوهم او وصفوا الحكم بالخطا القضائي
مئات الاشخاص
اتهموا بالشعوذه في تلك الفتره من هم
الكثير من النساء لعلى اشهرهم ما حدث في
ولايه ماسه تشوست
بالشهيره بمحاكمه سلف
اليس كذلك
في افلام كثيره طبعا وحتى
احنا طبعا محاكم التفتيش وكان
كثير يتهموا زورا وبهتانا بانهم ساحرات
ويحرقوا
بدي راح احرق شخص معين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات